the question or the point that I want to
raise uh is based on the topic of music
and uh the way or worship during the
form of
Music um and I just want to say this is
not to condemn us but to edify us is why
I'm raising this topic Christ came not
to condemn the world but that the world
might
save through him and personally I have a
challenge you know whenever I go to
Joint Services big services like this
one I have the challenge of having to
try to refrain myself in the house of
God to sing because of the manner in
which the worship is conducted and so I
always find it a challenge and it's a
sad thing for me to know that I'm in
church but I have to try to refrain
myself from singing because of the way
it is done instead servant of the Lord
said instead of it being a blessing
music is made a snare and there's a quot
quotation here that I want to read
quickly and then i' like Pastor to shed
as much light on it as possible
all right it says here and the heading
is music made a snare it says the things
you have described as taking place in
Indiana the Lord has shown me what take
place just before the close of probation
every uncut thing will be
demonstrated there will be shouting with
with drums music and dancing the senses
of rational beings will become so
confused that they cannot be trusted to
make right decisions a bed Lam of noise
shocks the senses and prts that which if
conducted a right might be a blessing
the powers of satanic agencies blend
with the den and the noise to have a
carnival and this is termed the holy
spirit's working those things which have
been in the past will be in the future
Satan will make music a snare by the way
in which it is conducted let us give no
place to the strange
exercising which really take the Mind
away from the deep moving of the Holy
Spirit God's work is ever
characterized by calmness and
dignity all
right let's
pray Our Father in heaven we thank you
for the promise of wisdom in James
1:5 if any of you like wisdom let him
ask of God so we ask youday God grant us
this wisdom and give me the words to
speak that even though I may say what is
Right help me to say it with the right
attitude in Jesus name I pray
amen I am familiar with the passage you
quoted my good
brother it is not a condemnation of
drums the passage is not condemning drum
any instrument can be misused okay elen
white is talking about the the there's
some there's a popular feeling that the
noisier you are the more of the spirit
you have and that is not true so it's
not a condemnation of a drum or a guitar
or trumpet or organ or piano it is the
way it is used and that's the point
she's making as she said this loud bedum
of noise is music is not noise are you
following me and so some people worship
differently from others I was in a if
you go to South Africa a black South
African church and they sing they cannot
stand still are you with me they just
cannot stand still and sing now I can't
come from the west and tell them stand
still I cannot do that because God knows
what's in the heart of the person but
ELO white is against this loud noise for
noise sake an environment in which it's
impossible to think clearly and as she
said the senses are be numbed which you
see at rock concert rap concerts
whatever the fundamental principle is do
all to the glory of is this for the
glory of God or is it for the glory of
the person singing or the musician on
the instrument
it must be for the glory of God and
somehow must draw those in attendance
into the presence of God you can't pick
one instrument over another to do that
it is the way it is played and the
motive must be the glory of God so that
song service is not a
performance special music is not a
display of the quality of my voice
it is an act of
worship and that's the thing that must
be kept always alive is this an act of
worship or is this a display of talent
and skill when Christ appeared to the
disciples in John 20 Thomas was not
present the disciples told him we've
seen the Lord and he said icept I shall
see in his hands see in his hands the
print of the nail nails and put my
finger into the print of the nails and
thrust my hand into his side I will not
believe Thomas depended on his senses
Nebuchadnezzar told the three Hebrew
boys now if he be ready that at what
time you hear the sound of the Cornet
flute harp sack saltery dma and all
kinds of music he Fall Down and Worship
the image which I have made well and so
the music was to contribute to
idolatry are you following me but if you
read Psalm
150 praise the Lord with a string
instruments and organs Praise Him upon
the loud sounding symbols upon the high
sounding symbols so we have a collection
of instruments in Psalm 150 for the
glory of God we have a collection of
instruments in Daniel 3 for the glory of
false gods it is how they are used and
the motive behind the use of the
instrument but the noisier of a service
is does not me make it the more spirit
filled because generally the spirit
Works in calm quiet environments so the
Bible says not in the Whirlwind or in
the fire or in the storm but in the
still small voice but I cannot come to
church and tell a church these are the
levels of decb that are
acceptable are you following me and so
it is your motive and it must be the
glory of God but when things get to
noisy then we could have a problem are
you following me we begin to sound like
other churches who deliberately try to
make it as noisy as possible with the
misunderstanding that this is the spirit
of God if you read how the Israelites
behaved when they worshiped the golden
calf it was chaos you read Exodus 32 5-6
they sat down to eat and drink and Rose
up to play Joshua said there is a sound
of War
Moses said no no no no they're
singing But Jo this thing sounds like
War Moses who had come right from the
presence of God said no the people are
singing and worshiping and they were
carrying on and when Moses came down he
was so upset he dropped the Ten
Commandments he had to get two more
pieces of stone and return to have them
written again and so we must be careful
not to sound like the sound of War so
that even a minister like Joshua
was
confused but I cannot judge the heart of
a person only God can do that but
certainly I can judge the effect that a
particular form of music has on people
all right that's as far as I can go
thank
you next uh
question good afternoon good afternoon
thank you for addressing the topic of
instruments with regards the
musicians if I am a professional
musician but also a Seventh Day Advent
yes is anything wrong with me playing
for a first day Church uhhuh oh I see
nothing wrong at all your presence there
may be light to the people are you
following me your presence there may be
light to the people now let me be very
very narrow-minded I would have a lot of
questions if it went the other
[Music]
direction am I speaking in
tongues I would have concerns if it went
in the other direction are you following
me
but if you if you believe you a remember
of God's Remnant with a special message
called The Three Angels messages if you
believe you're part of a group entrusted
with present truth and you are invited
surely
go
mhm I love when I'm invited to other
churches to
speak I go quickly and I charge them
nothing
but I have an opportunity to speak thus
said the Lord directly without being
controversial but
remember Israel was specially called by
God and they were different from every
other tribe on the face of the Earth Ela
says God has called his church in this
day as he called ancient Israel to stand
as a light in the
earth Jesus told the disciples ye are
the light of the world he did not say
that to everyone if you read Matthew 5:1
the Bible says and seeing the multitudes
he went up into a mountain and when he
was set his disciples came unto him and
he opened his mouth and thought them so
he told the disciples he the life of the
world he did not tell the
crowd so if you believe you are a member
of God's Remnant surely you have
responsibility to take that light
wherever you can without becoming a part
of the environment where you are is that
clear all right sister you're still on
your feet Yes just to clarify I would
have interpreted you saying if I'm asked
to minister there in song then it's okay
MH what if I'm there every week it's my
job to play for them am I enabling the
first day of worship mhm is that the
case no I want first I'd ask you to go
to Psalm 32:
I will instruct thee and teach thee in
the way which Thou shalt go I would send
you to Psalm 25:4 show me thy ways oh
Lord teach me thy paths i' sent it to
Isaiah 48:17 I am the Lord that teacheth
thee in the which Thou shalt go so you
ask God for conviction but God's people
are needed wherever there's
Darkness mhm they're
needed but you always ask God because
your final uh Authority must be
God you know many years ago I was
speaking at a conference not a religious
conference a social work conference and
someone heard me speak and came to me he
was a Sunday Minister and I was leaving
and he shouted hey I came back he said
you're a preacher I said yes he said
come to my church I said fine I went to
the church it was an hour from my house
and I spoke he said can you speak to
three straight Sundays I said yes so I
went three straight Sundays then I said
to him uh he said to me listen can you
come on Wednesday
nights I said yes and I went every
Wednesday night for 18 months until he
left that
church every Wednesday I drove an hour
to his church and taught the members the
results I left to
God every Wednesday for 18 months he
asked me to come and I went and the
members came they came and they notice
now I'm very serious about time start on
time end on time very almost at the
point of needing medication and the I
told them we're starting at 700 now I
was driving an hour every night I was in
the parking lot first then after a few
weeks they realized that they saw that
then they started coming on time if they
learned nothing else they certainly
learned a God of Prophecy is a God who
is on
time next next question good afternoon
Pastor yes my brother well beloved and
respect God bless you God bless you God
bless you thank you I need it I want to
um share something then post my question
at last okay but I would like to
reinforce my brother for sentiment on
the bedam of music as we can see um in
Daniel
37 music has been used by Satan that's
right to get the
to bow down and we are 7day Adventist
young people I love my brothers and
sisters in Christ we all once baptized
in this faith our name are written in
the Book of Life all right and I have
loved them and I would like to share
this
here it says music is the idol which
many professed saath keeping Christian
worship where are you reading from um is
taken from
messages to young people
269 I believe all right okay so say it
again music is the idol which many
professes have with keeping Christian
worship but what to want to reinforce is
what he mentioned earlier and this is a
warning to us right mhm taken from
second selected message page 36
paragraph 2 said the things you have
described as taking place in indiano the
Lord has shown me what take place just
before the close of probation so there's
a warning for the church
today every uncount thing will be
demonstrated there will be shout
shouting with
drums music and dancing the senses of
rational being will become so confused
that they cannot be trusted to make
right decision I'm sharing this to say
with my personal experience with the
type of worship we had this morning I
believe it was a bed Lam of nice mhm not
from my own experience but many other
person I had a chat with because right
now my head is swinging okay worship
cannot leave okay a person in this
state um again I love my young brothers
and sister is not to condemn you guys
but to educate okay um the senses would
become beown it affects our physical mhm
but my question is they say on the day
of
atonement we are in the day of
anti-typical
atonement right was drum a part of the
service thank you okay now I'm not aware
of drums being part of the service no
organs no pianos no trumpets no guitars
I'm not aware of that no I'm not I'm not
but let me say
this people are convicted at different
times in their lives Ela white was
called by God to be his servant I
believe November of
1844 she began keeping the Sabbath in
1846 even though the message came before
that she was not yet convicted are you
following me she was not convicted God
deals with people individually you know
Paul on the Mars Hill he said he said I
perceive that in all things you're too
superstitious for as I passed by and
beheld your devotions I found an altar
with this inscription to the unknown God
whom therefore ye ignorantly worship Him
declare I unto you some of the heathens
were worshiping God not knowing they
were worshiping the true God now the
opposite is also true some people are
worshiping Satan not realizing that's
the one they're worshiping there are
some people who are genuinely out of a
pure heart giving a certain service to
God not realizing God would want them to
do it a little differently and God will
find a way to direct them in that path
but so we have to be careful not to
cover a church with a blanket and say
that this thing is all bad God has a way
of directing his people step by step
there was a time when our Pioneers
smoked because they did not have the
health message there was a time they did
not return a tithe they did not have
that light as the light came and
conviction came they modified their
behavior so while it is true White made
that statement we have to ask to whom
was she speaking was she speaking to
season Adventist was she speaking to new
Converse to whom was she speaking our
services should be dignified at all
times yes but let us remember conviction
comes at different times to different
people so sometimes we have to be a
little patient a little long-suffering
as we deal with those who do things
differently from the way we
do um I just like to ask the members of
the congregation okay yes I'll just like
to ask
them the members of
the yes I'll just like to ask the
members of the congregation when asking
your questions due to time please take
30 seconds and get to the thank you very
much right
okay all right we're in the back well
not quite the back in the middle to the
left I see if I'm unequally yoke yes
without the knowledge of it yes after I
am married yes and I have the knowledge
mhm should I should I divorce my wife
no
no no no no no
M or your husband no
[Music]
like let us go to
uh 1 Peter chapter
3 1 Peter chapter 3 very uh
straightforward
question less than 30
seconds 1 Peter chapter
3 are you there not yet
yet do you have it my brother who asked
a question do you have 1 Peter chapter
3 does he have a Bible no
okay likewise you wives likewise well
let's pray again father as we read your
word give us light and understanding in
Jesus name I pray amen likewise ye wives
be in subjection to your own husbands
Now read carefully with me that if any
obey not the word come on they also
might without the word be what won by
the conversation of the wife while they
behold your Chase conversation coupled
with fear let me make that into simple
East Bank
English Peter is telling women married
to unconverted
men don't nag the man come to church
come to church don't do that two things
you be faithful to God let him see your
faithful life and the fact that you
still respect him as your husband
converted or not and Peter said those
two things may win that man so when he
says they may without the word be one to
the word without the word without
nagging one to the word the truth and so
my brother if your wife is an unbeliever
let her seek Christ in you let Christ
use you as the closest person to her to
bring her to the truth but do not
divorce your
wife we're in the
back good afternoon everyone good
afternoon my question is um well this is
based on someone who is uh uh was a
non-adventist and has now been converted
to adventism uhhuh but the individual is
struggling in the fact that the person
think that they're not being taught the
word of God as they were taught in the
church they came and so because um the
person believes that the leadership of
the church is lacking in regards to
teaching them the word of God they would
come to church some Sabbath but they are
not experiencing based on their
knowledge uh the word of God being
taught in the church so the person said
that they prefer to go back to the
church they came from go to hell knowing
that they're not worshiping on the
Sabbath but at least they're being
taught the word of God what
encouragement would you give to me to
give to encourage that person in God's
the light well I would take if I
understand you carefully the unbeliever
who comes to the Adventist Church chur
feels he or she is not getting enough
truth and wants to go back to a Sunday
church am I right okay yes I was point
the person to John chapter 6 let's go to
John 6 we read from verse
66 John 6 reading from verse
66 do you have
that you have the King James version
read with me what is John 666 saying
from that time many of his disciples
went back and walked no more with him
next verse then said unto the twel will
ye also go will you leave me read the
next
verse
zimon and said what Lord to whom shall
we go thou Hast the words of eternal
life now pause what is the Bible telling
us Peter told Jesus
we are staying with you because of what
you teach amen now if you have an
unbelieving spouse and the spouse thinks
he or she isn't getting enough truth you
can go to some other Adventist Church
but that person needs to understand that
God's end time people are a people who
obey his Commandments am are you
following me the person needs to
understand one of the distinguishing
features of God's end time church is the
fact that they lift up the law of God
which is an expression of the righteous
Life of Christ and so when God called
the Israelites out of Egypt he gave them
the
law in Revelation 22:14 blessed are they
that keep his Commandments that they may
have right to the tree of life so the
person needs to understand God's
peculiar end time people are those who
are distinguished by upholding his law
which is the righteous Life of Christ
and so if you don't get what you want
from one Church you go to another 7day
Adventist Church but you do not go back
back to Babylon are you following me
just to be satisfied with error let me
show you something else go to uh Luke
Chapter 5 let's read from verse 37 Luke
and this is a very frightening
expression it comes from Jesus very
frightening for those of you who do
evangelism consider this do you have
Luke
5 from verse
37 read with me what does that say no
man putteth new wine in into Old bottles
else the burst the bottles and be
spilled and the Shall Perish sh but new
wine must be put where new balls and
both are now read verse 39 carefully go
what does that say no one also having
drunk what old wine come on straightly
desireth new stop what does that mean
people accustomed to error do not
quickly yearn for truth yes yes no one
also having drunk all wine straightly
desireth new finish the
verse for he saith come on the old is
better there are people who stick with
their error simply because they're
accustomed to it you have to understand
that and so the fact that someone has
come to the church physically does not
mean the person has come spiritually
Lot's wife left the city physically she
did not leave the city
spiritually that spouse should be taught
carefully that God is looking for
truth those that worship Him must
worship Him in spirit and truth even if
the person goes back still encourage the
person to study because the spirit can
bring that person back but people need
to understand what God wants is truth
Jesus said in vain do they work worship
me teaching for doctrines the
Commandments of men we must learn the
Commandments of God and God's
Commandments are
truth and also pray a lot because the
Bible says the Lord added to the church
acts 2:47 daily such as should be say
only God can save a person you and I are
instruments but only God can save a
person pray for that person Ela says
preaching the truth is fine but if the
spirit does not take the truth to the
person's heart there is no conviction
you can't argue someone into the truth
you can pray them into the truth someone
else yes Pastor where is that oh right
there uh on Judgment Day we all will
stand before Jesus yes but to the best
of your knowledge uhhuh uh what will
happen to babies infants who didn't have
a chance to know what is right from
wrong okay all right
the Adventist
Church does not have a doctrinal
position on what will happen to
babies Ela white does say I don't recall
where but she says those who grew up in
slavery they had no chance to know about
Jesus at
all God will not raise him from the dead
he will leave them as they are he cannot
raise them to punish them because they
just did did not know but he cannot take
them to Heaven they would be Misfits he
just does not resurrect them and say
they have no clue now I've heard some
our preachers say babies that depends on
what happens to the
parents are you following me but there's
also this consideration that God looks
down the road and sees what life that
person would have lived and then God
could make a decision but what we do
know is that the Lord says I will be
merciful to of whom I will be merciful
and God does not condemn the
innocent that's as far as I can
go uh who has the
microphone
just yes good everybody good
evening well um the question is at this
point in
time if I continue to eat meat flesh
food would I be going to
heaven all right it's a good question if
I eat meat will I be going to heaven
again that's a decision that only God
can make and I also add to that if you
go contrary to your conviction then you
get into trouble with God there are some
people who eat meat and they are not
bothered at all because the truth about
the diet has not yet reached their
hearts but they are are faithful to God
and everything else God convicts people
at different times elen white finally
gave up meat in the late 1890s I believe
it was she finally gave it up completely
in the late 1890s she was God's Prophet
from
1844 that's when the full conviction
finally hit her now someone could have
gone to her and say well you shouldn't
be eating meat because she got the
health message I believe in 1863 or 1858
one de de ades before she finally gave
it up completely and so there is a
degree to which we allow people to work
with God but God's recommendation is to
avoid meat as much as we can
mhm completely if possible now you go to
some country let's
say New Guinea somewhere and people live
the the in the countryside all they know
is
fish and you go and you tell them stop
eating fish you may do more harm than
good that's all they know and the
servant of the Lord tells us when doing
evangelism as much as possible try not
to disrupt people's culture are you
following me and so while the ideal diet
is a plant-based diet there are some for
whatever circumstances they have may
have to eat whether fish or something
else but the ideal is a meatless diet
but I cannot say if you eat meat you'll
go to hell but I will say if you disobey
God you'll be lost
if you disobey God you'll be lost if
you're convicted and you keep doing it
you endanger your
soul who has the
mic good afternoon everyone I would like
to ask a question about marriage about
what marriage oh marriage mhm okay I was
married 20 years I'm married young but
my marriage didn't work out all right
the boy that I married to he was a
little bit abused so I'm trying to come
out was a little bit what
AB so I'm trying to come out to it but
he's not giving me my divorce what
should I do about it all right is he
Adventist pardon me is he an Adventist
he was an Adventist uh but he's not but
it didn't work out okay I think I dealt
with that question last last Sabbath The
Bible gives one clear cause for divorce
and that is adultery the one clear cause
for divorce in the Bible is adultery now
you may find yourself in a circumstance
that justifies separation but not
divorce separation but not divorce the
clear Bible basis for divorce is adul y
now if you establish he has committed
adultery that doesn't mean you have to
divorce him God is a god of
reconciliation if he's willing but if
he's not you have no choice but you
abuse May justify separation because you
not just stand there and be a punching
bag but it does not justify divorce the
reason for divorce is adultery and even
then you should pursue
reconciliation if possible but only you
can decide that the church can't tell
you that you have to decide that for
yourself because you are the one in the
difficult and trying situation but based
on what you said you may separate but
not
divorce all right next question um
Pastor I have this question to ask you
concerning yes
um that's
about um the way how I'm seen a lot of
people today they the way people do what
dressed okay and I
see they putting on these wet lips M CeX
nail polishes okay I want to since I
know before I become an Adventist I know
I see people they NE us to dress like
that now I'm seeing these things in the
church now so when the new converts come
into the church
they see they feel that this is normal
and I feel all these little things and
little bits there that what causing them
to question if they are in the right
Church okay I know if you want to shed
more light on
that
ah there's a way to
dress do I have your
attention I hear a lot of chatting so
I'll wait
there is a way to dress to glorify God
there's a way to sing to glorify God
there's a way to eat to glorify
God in the area of dress El white has
quite a bit to say about dress while she
does not give a lot of specific details
what color to wear or whatever but she
does say that dress should glorify God a
woman's dress should not contribute to
inflaming the passions of a man are you
following me one of the the earliest
principles in the Bible is found in
Genesis 4 let's go there quickly Genesis
chapter 4 and there's a particular word
I want you to look for and see if you
can identify it Genesis chapter
4 we read from verse
one when you found it say
Amen very few of you said amen how many
of you have Bibles can I see them oh
okay all right right you have Genesis 4
verse 1 let me pray again Father in
heaven give us wisdom as we seek to
answer these questions in Jesus name I
pray amen and Adam knew Eve his wife
when she conceived and bear Cain and
said I have gotten a man from the Lord
Now read the next verse for me and she
again bear whom his brother now we're
looking to see how often the word
brother occurs in Genesis 4 and she
again bear his brother AB
and Abel was the keeper of sheep but
Cain was the tiller of the ground and in
process of time it came to pass that
Cain brought of the fruit of the ground
an offering unto the Lord and Abel he
also brought of the firstlings of his
flock and of the fat thereof and the
Lord had respect unto Abel unto his
offering but unto Cain unto his offering
he had not respect and Cain was very WTH
and his countenance fell and the Lord
said unto Cain why are thy wroth and why
is thy countenance Fallen if thou doest
well shalt thou not be accepted and if
thou doest not well sin Li at the door
and unto thee shall be his desire and he
shall R and thou shalt rule over him now
verse eight and Cain talked with Abel
his brother twice and it came to pass
come on when they were in the field that
Cain rose up against Abel his brother
and slew him and the Lord said unto Cain
where is Abel thy brother and he said
what I know not am I My Brother's Keeper
and he said what hast thou done the
voice of thy brother's blood cth unto me
from the the ground and now thou curse
from the earth which hath open her mouth
to do what receive thy brother's now
it's the only chapter where the word
brother occurs so much in the entire
Bible what's the lesson for us when God
said where is Abel thy brother what was
God telling Cain now God knew the
principle is we are to some degree
responsible for one
another the way a woman dresses
exerts an effect on a
man are you following me now anyone will
tell you men are primarily affected by
sight that's why prostitutes dress the
way they dress if they can show you they
may make a sale they are affected by
sight now a woman dressing in the church
must take into consideration the
possible effect her dress has on someone
else men must take the same thing into
consideration but even though women are
not affected by this as much as men are
men are visual now a man has to be
careful what he says to a
woman are you following me he has to be
careful of what he tells her because
what he says may not be what she
processes and so on the issue of dress
there's several considerations when you
buy an outfit your question is I want to
dress to look like a child of God now
the church cannot tell you all the
details but surely if your bus line is
here right where your hemline is we have
a problem are you following me and so
you you the spirit ELO white says the
new birth is a rare experience in this
age of the world this is the reason why
there are so many perplexities in the
churches people are not
converted many so many who claimed the
name of Christ are unconverted and
Unholy they've been baptized they were
buried alive self did not die and so
they did not rise to newness of life
with Christ there are there's a lot of
unconv verion in the church many of
these questions can be settled if we are
truly led by the spirit of God because
the spirit is not the spirit of
confusion he is the spirit of unity and
the spirit that convicts you will
convict me it doesn't mean I wear what
youw but it simply means both of us will
follow the principle of is this for the
glory of God and will this cause a
negative effect on the spiritual life of
my brother it is not enough for lady to
say well what he thinks is his business
no that's not a Biblical principle we
can contribute to a person's spiritual
condition up or down and so my sister
when Adam and Eve sinned they made
aprons of leaves an apron is not not
complete covering when God cover them he
covered them with what quats of skin the
lesson for us is when you dress cover
yourself and always ask God father do I
represent you you do not dress to look
better than someone else you dress to
glorify God when God gave Moses
instructions regarding Aaron's garments
the Bible says in Exodus 20 29:2 I think
it is is said Thou shalt make holy
garments for Aaron for Glory and for
beauty now listen carefully for Glory
and for beauty Aaron first had to do
what reflect God then Beauty came for
Glory God's Amazing Grace page 322
paragraph 2 the glory of God is his
character and we know that from Exodus
33: 18-2 34 uh 5 5
to8 Glory
first then Beauty God is the god of
beauty but Glory comes first and that
must be the motive when we choose
clothing we must also consider male or
female that we do not have an adverse
effect on members of the opposite sex
also there are certain ways you cannot
dress and walk into a
courtroom are you with me the judge will
put you out well this is is where the
judge of the whole earth of the whole
world is if you're going to trial for
whatever crime let's say a young man and
you dress like one of the rappers your
attorney if he really cares about it
will tell you don't dress like that when
you come before the judge don't wear a
cap turned around dress differently
because the way you look will have an
effect on that judge and may affect the
sentence you get and so again for the
glory of God but let's not run around
the Church policing
people are you with
me did you hear what I said don't police
people but surely if you have a
relationship with someone you can talk
to the person policing people is not a
spiritual gift but if you know the
person you can say listen can I talk to
you and then speak very humbly very
humbly knowing that two Sinners are
having a discussion all right
yes good afternoon Pastor uhhuh Grace
and peace um there's a teaching that is
pervasive in Christianity today and even
amongst us as God's professed people
uhhuh now it is the believe that we'll
be sinning until Jesus Christ come okay
moreover there's a teaching also that
stated that um none of us will be
perfect only when Jesus Christ come
uhhuh so I'm asking the question for
edification purpose can we be perfect
before Jesus Christ come we're required
to be perfect before Jesus Christ come
Christ cannot take imperfect people into
a perfect world if you look at the way
things began we can get some idea of how
things must end when God made Adam and
Eve and put them in charge of the world
what condition were they in they were
perfect God's ideal is perfect people in
charge of a perfect world before Christ
comes he makes perfect people then he
puts them in a perfect world which will
be the reverse Perfection is required
simple reasoning how many sins did Adam
commit that led to his eviction one if
God put Adam out for one can he let you
in with one no God requires Perfection
but that Perfection is in Jesus Christ
who is in you are you with me it is the
Perfection of Christ in you which
countes yours let me say that again it
is the Perfection of Christ in you that
counts as yours God's standard has
always been Perfection Ela white writes
God requires at this time just what he
required of the Holy pair in Eden
perfect obedience to his
law quickly um is it okay also for a
Christian young man to have a long
plated ear to long have long what plated
ear Oh Oh you mean dread
[Applause]
talks
okay want to
that I'll wait until you're ready
pray
okay all
right well I'll wait for you to settle
down then I'll
pray Father in Heaven the question was
asked with good
intentions grant me wisdom I pray in
Jesus name
amen a few years ago
I was at a youth
conference and I made an appeal for
people to give their lives to Christ and
to serve
him and this young man came and he had
dreadlocks he wanted to be a Bible
worker so I said and the place where he
lived mainly white people lived so I
said what do you think the effect will
be if you walk up to the door of some
white person and you have that kind of
hairstyle I didn't ask for an answer I
just had him to
think and I said did you have it for the
glory of God and I didn't ask for answer
I just left him a week later he took it
all
off because he he concluded
no I was in another country speaking to
youth group and I gave them the
principle I gave you some night ago I
believe in any decision you make the
first question is is this for the glory
of God there there was a young lady
present who had uh this is no joke a
hairstyle with all kinds of
additions and as I used to describe it
as a small Eagle's Nest on her head
that's the way it looked and then I
spoke about for the glory of
God the next morning I was doing
onetoone counseling and she came and I
didn't recognize her she took it all off
then she told me who she was and I said
what happened she said well the spirit
convicted me
and I took it
off I was in another country doing a
week of prayer made a call for baptism
this man come came every night a real
raster you know what a raster is every
night I mean with
the and on the morning of and he
accepted to be baptized on the morning
of the baptism while I was preaching he
went to the back of the
church and when he came back nobody
recognized him he went back there and
cut everything off came up and got
baptized now that's what they did under
conviction then the question the
principle Remains the Same when you
choose a hairstyle were you thinking of
the glory of God that's all I'm
saying and again we don't police people
you can preserve piety without policing
members the question is were you
thinking of the glory of God when you
bought those
shoes and only you can answer
that but I can't come and tell you now I
was at a church in Los Angeles they had
standards for coming up on the
pulpit are you with me you could not
come up with Dre uh dreadlocks you could
not come up with 9in heels you could not
come out with your armpits exposed you
could not come up if your dress was
above your knee they had stand that you
could come to church you could not come
with that
pit now that was that church are you
following me and so if you sincerely ask
is this for the glory of God you'll be
surprised how the spirit will change
your behavior and mine as a matter of
fact if you and I would go to our
closets tonight and look at all that we
have and say which is which of these was
for the glory of God we may have to go
the next day and buy an entirely
different
wro I was in South Africa many years ago
at a restaurant and I told you the story
I believe this waitress came with a
piece of metal in her
nose and I said why did you do that she
said because I wanted
to that's the reason most of us do what
we do because I wanted
to ask yourself is is this for the glory
of God and then listen to the spirit all
right next
question yes who has the mic oh
okay Jesus came in human form
yes was it prior to the fall of Adam or
after the fall of Adam good question
finally we have a theological
question not one based on outward
Behavior
okay let's go to Hebrews 2
Hebrews 2 let's read from
verse 10 let's read from verse
9 of Hebrews
2 do you have
that when you have say Amen read with
me but we see Jesus who was made a
little lower than the angels for the
suffering of death now crowned with
Glory and Honor that's how how humanity
is described in Psalm 8 verse 5 that's
Jesus that he by the grace of God should
taste death for every man now did he
come in Adam's condition or before
Adam's condition if he came before
Adam's condition before Adam's sin he
could not die sorry he could not
die why what's the only reason for death
sin someone who comes in Adam's sinless
condition cannot die of course the
mystery of Christ but he took our sin
Adam had no sin at all not his nor taken
from anybody else death could not fall
on Adam or someone in Adam's pristine
sinless condition in order for Christ to
die he had to come under the
condemnation of the law and only sin
brings that about I'm not saying Jesus
sin he never sinned but he took the
Bible says he took our sins into his own
body 1 Peter 2:24 he came in Adam's
condition after Adam fell not before
Adam
fell
yes hi Pastor no no no my brother has a
followup yes sorry sorry can you prove
that from one more text please one more
text yes let's go let's stay in Hebrews
very good I appreciate that very okay
let's stay in Hebrews let's look at
verse 11
are you there of Hebrews 2 read with me
for both he that sanctifieth and they
who are Sanctified are all of One keep
reading for which cause he's not ashamed
to call them Brethren go to verse
14 for as much then as the children are
partakers of Flesh and Blood keep read
he also himself likewise took part of
the same that through death he might
destroy him that had a power of death
that is the devil and deliver them who
through fear of death were all their
lifetime subject to bondage read 16 now
for verily he took not on him the nature
of angels but he took what the seed now
who is the Seed of Abraham David with
his adultery and murder Solomon with all
his hundreds and hundreds of wives B
Sheba and her adulterous relationship
with David Rahab the Harlot that is the
seed through which Christ came but he
never sinned himself so he took our
condition without taking our
Behavior are you following me and so the
Bible says in 2 Corinthians 5:21 for he
hath made him to be sin for us who knew
no sin he knew no sin that we might be
made you see go to 2 Corinthians 5:21
quickly it's one of the most important
verses in the entire Bible 2 Corinthians
5:21 we look look at it
microscopically are you there read with
me for he who is he no it's not Jesus
who is he God the Father for he hath
made him who's him Jesus to be S for us
who knew no sin now when you read who
knew no sin to whom does that refer
Jesus that we might be made the
righteousness of God in him now how many
times do you see the word made
don't look at me look at the verse
twice the first time to whom is it
applied no no no who was
made Jesus was made what he had to be
made sin because he didn't
sin are you not with
me someone made him sin he did not make
so he never chose to sin now that we
might be
made someone has to make us righteous
why because we have none someone had to
make Jesus a sinner because he had none
so the very way God made righteous Jesus
to be a sinner is the same way he makes
sinful me to be
righteous are you following me Jesus
knew no sin I know no
righteousness God made him a sinner but
he never sined sinned God makes me
righteous I have no righteousness of my
own so when you say perfection is
required the righteousness of Christ is
perfection and it's given to us it was
the Fallen nature of Adam he took mhm
that's the beauty of the gospel God can
produce his character in someone who has
the carnal
nature now you can understand the
character of God in Adam before he
sinned because he begins sinless but to
produce the character of God in someone
born
sinful that is a miracle that's what the
gospel does but it is god making Christ
a sinner it is god making us righteous
because Christ never sin we're not
righteous
naturally God took Christ took Adam's
condition after the fall go to Hebrews
chapter 4 read verse1 15 quickly Hebrews
4:15
do you have that what does that say for
we have not an high priest which cannot
be touched with the feelings of our
infirmities but was in all points
tempted like as we are yet without sin
Christ never chose to sin we choose to
sin when El says Christ had no
propensity to sin we can develop a
propensity through constant habit you
can develop a propensity to steal by
constantly stealing are you following me
I have no propensity to rob a bank I
have no propensity to kill somebody but
I can develop it if I Rob One Bank are
you following me because what you
venture to do once you're more apt to do
again a propensity is an established
habit based on
practice Christ never per practiced any
sin so he had no propensity but he have
the possibility of sinning yes that's
why the devil tempted him remember Satan
was the most intelligent being God ever
made El said when he left Heaven he took
all his power with him he was closest to
Christ he knew Christ he knew Christ
could sin that's why he
tempted next question thank you for that
theological question I appreciate it yes
my brother hi Pastor I don't know if
this question is a
theological we're listening r romantic
evangelism Pastor romantic
evangelism if I seek to if I fall in
love with someone uh-huh who's outside
of the church you shouldn't fall in love
in the first place but go
[Music]
ahead with intent yes that I will bring
them over and you know witness to them
and so
on is is it is it okay in in those
situations to have a relationship no no
simple answer no no now let me say that
the person may get baptized you'll never
know if the person got baptized for you
or for Jesus you'll never
know always start God's way at every
step the only safe way to go I'm not
passing condemnation I'm simply saying
remember the tough quotation I decided
not to give you last week at
allness I won't give you now either
it's too tough It's too tough too
tough nah too hard it's too hard
H should I tell
[Applause]
you okay here it
is Child Guidance now I'm not telling
you it's too rough okay I'll tell
you uh the Adventist home paid
67 paragraph 1 anyone has L writings on
the phone I'll let you read it and I
won't read
it Adent is home page
67 paragraph
one but since you're taking half an hour
to find it I'll have to tell
you I really don't want to but okay
I'm really troubled I really am troubled
I should not have raised it in the first
place okay
okay to connect with an
unbeliever is to place yourself on
Satan's ground
ground you grieve the spirit of God and
forfeit his
protection what does forfeit
mean you give up to connect with an
unbeliever is to place yourself on
Satan's ground you grieve the spirit of
God and forfeit his
protection you see why I didn't want to
say
that's
rough that's
tough all right someone ask an easy
question
um they are
preachers but they administrate
differently they are what they
are oh preachers yes yes yes but they
administrate differently you mean they
preach differently yeah okay all right
what's the question it's not question
just they want to
um like how they will be a preacher but
they will administrate differ okay am I
supposed to say
something no no I'm very serious I'm
very serious what's the
question just a statement okay all right
okay okay okay yes there are people are
different yes yes yes but we must try to
present the truth okay all right Pastor
yes my brother isn't there cultures in
the
world where men go to hairong the
Aborigines in America certain parts of
India Africa that's their culture yes so
when they become Christians yes they
must cut their hair to look like the
white people oh no no
[Laughter]
no look like white people
okay okay let me uh I don't recall where
this statement is I can find it for you
very quickly here's what ELO said the
truth affects all
nationalities the same way we have to
trust the power of the spirit not the
power of
culture are you following me we must
trust the power of the spirit not the
power of culture
a person truly converted will do as the
spirit directs but God doesn't want an
Indian to look like a white man no or an
African to look like a Scandinavian no
but all of them will look like children
of
God okay I thought I was getting another
theological question I didn't yeah good
afternoon Pastor yes as you know I sat
there listening to you whole week okay
you know it is very spirit filled all
right but it God we wonder and this is
the question that I'm posing this
afternoon mhm how come or this question
I have to think how I'm going to say it
uhhuh how is it or why is it that from
that same Pulpit yes that we do not hear
present truth uh-huh we only get
precious truth all the time what is
precious truth well things that are nice
and entertaining I I don't know the
sister said very correctly different
people say different things God puts
different emphasis on different people
so I cannot account for what other
people say nor do I question the
sincerity what I'm saying is this uhhuh
is that this entire week we spirit
filled uh-huh and it was difficult I I
watched and I recognize it was difficult
for many people to understand the things
deeply what you said uhhuh and that is
present truth okay and if they had been
getting this often times it would be
easy for them to okay I understand what
you're saying I understand especially
from the word of God okay constant
exposure all right okay okay but well I
don't know what to say um all I can say
is God tells different people to say
different things that's all I can
say and may God bless all preachers
everywhere all right who is next hi good
night Pastor who is
supervising just who's supervising the
questions or does anyone take the mic
anytime he or she wants oh okay okay I
thought God is not the auth of confusion
but go ahead yes this is a question we
had raised in Bible study if a person
get a loan from the bank do they tithe
it one a loan from the bank do they pay
tithes on it is that increase in in
funds I mean they have to pay back the
loan with interest
so what's the loan for to build a house
to build a house build a house buy a car
you end up with a house you didn't have
before yes is a house part of your
possessions if the government assess
your wealth yes
yes give God
his listen to me carefully you cannot
give God too
much now I know I just said something
unpopular you cannot give God too
much do you realize all belongs to him
in the first place he can take it
the Bible
says freely well no that's not what I
want give to God press down overflowing
and God will return it to you mhm our
thinking must always be how can I give
to God not how can I keep from
him if God thought like that he would
have sent an angel to die not Jesus and
salvation would not have worked all
right next
question good afternoon Pastor good
afterno I have a question on working on
the Sabbath yes if I am to put on my
clothes a Sabbath morning and head out
and my neighbor's house is on fire uhuh
I have to call the fire uh fire service
yes to come and help yes so they have to
be working and their service services
are essential MH are there certain
exemptions to certain people who can
work on the Sabbath or are there very
good question very good question there's
a great day when you use the word
exemption now if you exempt the
fireman you have to exempt the policeman
you have to exempt the plumber you have
to exempt the whom electrician you have
to exempt the soldier protecting the
country then the list of exemptions
never end you understand me God you know
ELO white writes in Patriarchs and
Prophets page 479 paragraph 2 God Lord
shut Moses out of Canaan to teach a
lesson which should never be forgotten
that it is man's exact obedience this is
what he wants now in Exodus 34: 25 I
believe it is El says when you go up to
the feast I will not allow anyone to
desire your land I will protect it God
protects those who are faithful to him
now if your neighbor is not and your
neighbor's house is on fire you have to
do something you just can't walk and say
I'm off to church you have to do
something as the spirit of God directs
you what would you want your neighbor to
do if your house were on fire but I
cannot stand from a desk and say it's
all right for the fireman to work it's
all right for the policeman to work I
can't do that in it Thou shalt not do
any work simple as that now you may say
I am a doctor I a nurse I told this some
group the last time El white informs us
any compensation doctor or a nurse
receives must be given to the church
because you're not to earn a living on
Sabbath Jesus says if your animal falls
into a pit you take it
out and so that's as far as I can go but
I cannot say it's okay for the firemen
to work because Jesus says it's lawful
to do good it's not lawful to
work you obey God and leave the rest to
him thank you for your answer yes
someone on the Facebook page is also
asking uh if it is okay for women to
wear pants that is not my question women
to wear pants or pants
yeah Deuteronomy 22:5 says a woman
should not wear that which pertaineth to
a man nor should a man wear that which
pertaineth to woman the principle is
there should be a clear differentiation
between the sexes
when God made Adam and
Eve the only physical inflamation we
have about them is
gender we don't know color of skin color
of eyes texture of hair height weight
all we know physically is one was male
and one and that's repeated more than
once clearly then gender is an important
issue with God when a man dresses and a
woman dresses I must know that's a man
that's a woman I was in an airport
Chicago and there were two people in
front of me and they were holding hands
and touching each other walking along
and I wanted to see who they were so I
walked quickly and turned around there
were two men and I couldn't
tell I have gone up to a man to say
listen sir can you help me when I turned
around it was a man it was a I I went to
say ma'am could you help me it was a man
you men have these buns now in these
years I thought it was a woman the
fundamental principle is is this clearly
a man is this clearly a
woman there are some countries where it
is so cold that women wear pants under
the dress it is so
cold I do not condemn a woman who wears
pants and again it depends on how she
wears it in other words if it looks as
if it was painted on with a brush are
you following
me then we we've got a
problem but there's some loose fitting
pants that look perfectly fine the
church at large has no ruling on pants
are you following me so when it comes to
should you wear pants or not I leave
that to the conscious of the person and
God there are women's blouses that look
like shirts but I wouldn't wear them
because they're clearly made for the
woman in the Middle East men wear what
looks like gowns women wear what looks
like gowns but in their culture they
know who is who again the principle of
dress one for the glory of God two the
genders should not be
confused that's as far as I can
go now when I was a when I was a boy in
the church you couldn't wear pants on
the pulpit nobody wore pants to church
when I was a if the church heard you
wore pants downtown they'd call
you mhm why were you in pants they'd
call
you there was this there's there's a
street in Barbados where the ladies of
the night would be if the church found
out you walked down that street the head
Elder would call you why are you walking
down Nelson Street but the church has
changed drastically but the principle is
the glory of God do not confuse genders
because gender is the only physical item
we have to describe Adam and Eve yes
good afternoon Pastor happyb even oh
Happ Sabbath to you so I have been
observing you uh with your sermons you
have the Bible open in front of you yes
however degree of accuracy that you call
the the book The chapter the verse the
degree of accuracy that you recite the
actual scripture even with the the
question and answers when you you
reference scripture my question to you
is how do I get on your level in terms
of that serious question all right may I
correct your question it should be how
can I get to my level I mean your own
level because God has requirements of
you he doesn't have of me are you
following me God gave one one man in the
parable five talents he gave another two
and another one the one with five got
five more he got 10 Jesus said or the
master said well done the one with two
got two more the master said the same
thing well done numerically they were
different qualitatively they were the
same what do I mean by that 5 to 10 is
100% increase am I right 2 to 4 is 100%
increase 100 isn't more than 100 and so
God wants you to use the skills he's
given you to your ability not to mine
because your ability May exceed Mine by
Miles so you do what you can do my
recommendation is Elo white says that
which at first seems Difficult by
constant repetition grows easy that is
how I approach memorization every day
every day every day all day finding
reason to recite something all day all
day really all day mhm there's no easy
way but the more you do it the better
you become truly
really thank you for the question my
good sister yes so good afternoon
everyone hello so if there are angels
yes and other unfallen worlds that
worship God MH why did he go on to
create human beings knowing that we
would sin knowing that he would have to
send his son to die knowing that most of
us would be lost in the end uhh why did
he go on to create human beings did he
use us so that the other unfollowers or
Angels could see the effects of
sin okay sister that question is as old
as the
hills um let me talk to mothers let me
talk to mothers how many mothers do we
have okay when you decided to have a
child did you know your child will fall
while trying to walk yes sir no did you
know your child would have the MS or the
measles or childhood diseases yes or no
did you know you know the child may turn
out to be like one of these children AB
yeah but why did you still have
them H why did you still have
them because you wanted to love that
child are you with me God still made us
he wanted to love us now God didn't make
us to teach us what sin is like sin is
is never God's desire and only God can
tell you ultimately why he he made us
but God in somewhere El said we were cre
brought into existence because we were
needed now when I read that my eyes
popped we were brought into existence
because we were needed she also says
Humanity was a brand new
species different from those and
unfallen worlds different from Angels a
brand new species that's is as much as I
can say but God will have to tell you
all the details as to why but I'm glad
uh he let me live I'm sure you're glad
he let you live somebody
else a theological question something
about Grace justification the second
coming all right um good afternoon
everyone good after good afternoon uh my
question relates to the Bible's
reference to Wine in various aspects yes
um
is it a case where in some of the
aspects it was alcoholic wine or was it
non-alcoholic all right especially where
um Jesus turned the water into wine and
where he and his disciples SED and they
drank wine Etc okay okay let's look at
the very first
introduction of wine in the Bible the
very first go to num uh Genesis
9 Genesis
9 let's read from verse 21 of Genesis
9 do you have that no all right al8
Genesis 9 this is Noah the first
introduction in the Bible of wine
alcohol and wine can be alcohol or can
be just as juice do you have Genesis
9:21 what does that
say and he drank of the wine and was
drunken and he was uncovered come on
within his stent so we have wine and we
have drunk clearly this is what
alcohol he drank of the wine and was
drunken he was uncovered within his St
and what keep reading
and the father of come on saw the naked
and told his two Brethren without but
let's read verse 24 what does verse 24
say and Noah awoke from his wine and
knew what his younger son now what do
you understand by he awoke from his
wine he was
drunk he did not know that's our first
introduction to alcohol and it is not
good let's look at the second
introduction well you can't have a
second introduction the second mention
of why go to Genesis
14 are you in Genesis 14 Abraham has won
a battle to recapture lot and he brings
back all the captures the women the
goods he brings back lot in his Goods
Verse 18 of Genesis 14 read with me
and melkisedek come on King of s brought
forth Bread and Wine and he was the
priest of the most high God now the
priesthood of Jesus Jesus is modeled on
which priesthood
melchisedec do you think that was
alcohol or just grape juice grape juice
because Christ has told us through his
Old Testament writers wine is a mocker
strong drink is Raging now here we have
wine is a mocker strong drink raging one
defines the other there's a difference
between wine that's the juice and wine
that's alcohol now Jesus inspired
Solomon to write that Jesus cannot
produce alcohol in John Chapter 2 at a
wedding at Bethany just by simple
reasoning now there's a book written by
one of our former Scholars Baki he an
entire book on this subject if you can
find it read it very when he shows
linguistically the difference between
how the word wine is used in the Bible
and that the Bible does not support the
use of alcohol it supports the use of
wine not alcohol as a matter of fact uh
I was reading somewhere to my eternal
consternation Ela white saw
Satan in a meeting with his left
tenants and they met to discuss how to
destroy
Humanity each one had to submit an
idea Satan submitted
alcohol and look how successful it has
been the the wine Christ approves is
juice not
alcohol all right someone
else when do I stop where's Dr
Higgins Where is
he all right he's abandoned me okay yes
Pastor brothers sisters pleasant good
evening all right my question is Pastor
does everyone have a guardian angel yes
the reason I did ask the question you
did just say um prior to the question
over there that persons do forfeit the
protection of God and I do remember
reading somewhere that there is not um
justification for known sin I do not
quite remember where that is so is it a
case whereby we have recording angels
and not necessarily Guardian Angels
afforded to every single person on the
face of the Earth all person everyone
has
yes okay we all have an angel that
protects us we all in Matthew 18 talks
about the Angels do behold the face of
God meaning God's people we all have an
angel now we also all have the Holy
Spirit to varying degrees now the spirit
can function two ways in the life of the
believer the spirit convicts and
restrains are you with me the spirit
convicts and restrain restrains when
someone has rejected the spirit to the
point of crossing the line the spirit
only restrains he no longer convicts and
so and after these things I saw four
Angels standing on the four corners of
the Earth holding the Four Winds of the
earth that is restraint not
conviction the spirit and the angels
restrain the evil
angels God restrains Satan they don't
convict them they restrain them and so
the spirit restrains and convicts the
believer but when someone has cast off
the spirit through constant rejection
the spirit works as a restraint not a
convicting Force M but we all have a
guardian angel yes as a matter of fact
ELO tells us in the resurrection your
angel will take you up to Jesus in the
sky I like look forward very much to
seeing that beautiful picture okay God
bless you God bless
you this the last question according to
the man who just came up
so I'm asking this question on behalf of
somebody the person would like to know
how do we deal with pastors who were not
called by God but did call themselves
they're not called by God they called
themselves okay how do we deal with that
as a church or okay all right
okay that is you're asking me to pass a
judgment that's the last question
question I was told to make that the
last question you're asking me to make a
judgment and I can't make a judgment I
don't know who is called by God or who
sent himself what I do know is if you
send yourself the results of your work
will not uh be according to God's will
for you God sends people when you send
yourself you're not representing God you
do more harm than good now some people
approach the ministry as a career it is
a calling are you with me if you're an
evangelist you don't retire you may
retire from tents or whatever else you
don't retire from evangelism only when
you're dead and so God is the one who
will eventually identify who was called
and who wasn't because wolves can often
look very much like sheep so please
don't pass judgment on pastors saying
well you were not called and he was sent
by the fruits of the person you may have
some good idea as to who was called or
who was sent let me thank you very much
for your questions may the Lord bless
you let me urge you study the word of
you see God will answer your questions
personally Jesus said when he the spirit
of Truth is come he will guide you into
all truth it's guaranteed John 7:17 If
any man will do his will he shall know
the doctrine a willingness to obey God
is essential to understand the word of
God and let me just urge you you know
Jesus said the first commandment is thou
shallal love the Lord thy God the second
is love your neighbor he also said about
the weightier matters of the law what
did he mean by that there are some
subjects that should take priority
justification by faith the return of
Jesus Christ the five pillars of
adventism the second coming state of the
Dead the sanctuary the spirit of
Prophecy and what's the other one that I
left out the sanctuary I think those are
the five pillars of our faith that
constitute present truth if you Focus
there all other areas will eventually
become clearer to you may the Lord bless
you and put a double blessing on your
children let's pray Father in heaven we
thank you for this session of questions
I pray in the name of Jesus no one will
leave offended or angry give us all a
consciousness of our need for you bless
us I pray and may this church be the
reason why many in this community will
be ready to meet Christ when he comes I
pray from my heart in Jesus name amen
[Music]